foreign
[Applause]
TV special and these are the Forgotten
characters in The Tekken franchise
[Music]
thank you
other
you have conquered Olga now the key to
control logger is disappointed it was
all heihachi's evil plot I'll never let
heihachi get away with this no Julia
wait
Julia hatred is not the answer do you
remember why I taught you the powers to
fight it was to protect Mother Earth not
to destroy
now let's go home back to Arizona where
the land awaits us
[Music]
he's dead
what you died in that explosion
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
my house
thank you
[Music]
foreign
Roger Jr
[Music]
perfect perfect
what's this
you're kidding me is this some kind of
joke
ah
stop that
[Music]
democracy
thank you
[Music]
what is the problem
are you waiting hurry up and destroy him
listen well
foreign
[Music]
thanks for watching be sure to leave a
like And subscribe also huge shout out
to our patreon supporters if you want to
further support this Channel and making
more content like these please visit the
link to our patreon page below the
description
[Music]
foreign